je prends geler les beaux matchs sont
toujours des matches comme ça l'un d'eux
le frappe automatiquement un beau match
comme un siav est un bon gars comme
mcenroe qui est l'opposition des styles
c'est un petit peu ils ont comme la boxe
un virement ça sera trop là le battant
contre le styliste après toujours un bon
match jusqu'à l'enfant dans le conte
wendel en finale se voler la demi finale
il faut qu'il passe le suédois quand
même conséquent g d'herbe là on ne sait
pas ce qui peut arriver ça va être très
bien là
le suédois qui peut aller en finale
parce qu'aujourd'hui il était un
formidable héritage asphyxié totalement
becker qui ne savait plus quoi faire
l'été perdu 1 vers le dernier set il a
laissé filer
donc je souhaite une finale le compte je
crois comme tout le monde le groupe
wendel voyant les passeurs de la voir